Jabari terrific last two games
especially since halftime of game number
one as Seth pointed out Seth Greenberg's
here is just the different ways that you
were able to score today what do you
take take away here from these first two
Summer League games
um just coming out here you know uh just
taking advantage of it not not thinking
I'm too good for it just just coming out
here trying to get better you know what
I mean so that's what I'm trying to do I
think you must have learned that from
coach Pearl because I'm sure he's going
to take full credit for it
Greenberg I ain't talked to you since
Auburn what's up buddy how you doing man
congratulations I'm happy for you hey
you know one of the things that really
impressed me I I we had this quote that
you had about why you were playing and
and to me it's such a great message you
know the 20 years and uh 20 years old
you know 22 and 60 last year it wasn't
perfect and you just you want to get
rich explain that because a lot of times
with low management and everything else
you're in love with the game and you
just want to come out and compete what
one through your mind when they asked
you about playing in summer league
um it says you know you just gotta like
it's his game of refs you know what I'm
saying the crowd the fans the whistle I
usually don't get that during the summer
so just coming out here and competing
you know I'm saying like like nobody's
too good for it you come out here get
reps get better and um get ready for the
season you know with a new coach coming
in just learning new offense playing
with new teammates and just just having
fun I love playing the game it's so
refreshing yeah we've just showed uh the
new Brain Trust uh and your head coach
emeodoka is sitting across the way from
you Dylan Brooks is here today yep Fred
Van Vleet when you think of these guys
coming in
um you know how are they going to help
make your job easier here in year two
um just just their minds you know I'm
saying Fred Van fleet's a champion Dylan
Brooks has been deep in the playoffs
he's he's won a lot of games it's like
just their experience with with with
playing at the highest level and and
what they've seen is just that's who
wouldn't want that on their team you
know what I'm saying so so it's just
just good to have him with us and and
hopefully we can learn from him and they
can they can help us turn this thing
around
what kind of messaging does coach udoku
giving you as as you come to summer
league as you've been with around him in
some practices what kind of
communications he give to you and and
what kind of role does he want you to
embrace
um out here in some of that he's just
telling me to lead you know I'm saying
use my voice
um um it's good to learn how to live
earlier than later so he's always
telling me to just leading and um try to
use my voice and and focus on defense
and focus on ways to to improve and help
this team
Jabari thanks for joining us terrific
game continue having a great summer
league I appreciate you that's a good
man right there